اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في سعه اخباريه مفصله
بالعربيه نبداها بالعناوين
اشتباكات متقطعه في ام درمان واعلانه حاله
الطوارئ بولايه البحر الاحمر الشرقي
السودان
مبعوث البرهان في القاهره لبحث الازمه وسط
دعوات لحوار عاجل بين الجيش والدعم السريع
الامم المتحده ترسل وفدا الى السودان
لاستكشاف السبل اغاثه ملايين المتضررين من
حرب السودان
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
عقب وفاه الاسير خضر عدنان وزير الامن
الاسرائيلي يرفع حاله التاهب في السجون
ويحادير الاسرى من الاضراب
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم في نشره مفصله من
العربيه وتغطيه متواصله لازمه السودان
التي تدخل يومها 18 حيث قالت قوات الدعم
السريع انها اسقطت الطائره ميجا في
الخرطوم في وقت استيقظ صباح اليوم سكان
الخرطوم على ذوي قصف مدفعي خاصه في منطقه
تطورات تحدث بينما تم اعلانه حاله الطوارئ
لمده شهر على الاقل في ولايه البحر الاحمر
الشرقي السودان وفي اطار اعاده انتشار
القوات الامنيه داخل العاصمه قال المكتب
الصحفي لقوات الشرطه السودانيه ان الشرطه
بدات ارسال تعزيزات امنيه للتامين الاسواق
والمحلات التجاريه والاحياء كما اشارت
الشرطه الى قيامها بحملات خلال الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه في عدد من مناطق جنوب
الخرطوم بمشاركه وتنسيق امني مشترك مع
القوات المسلحه
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر منصورين ان
شاء الله الله اكبر الله اكبر جاهزين
[تصفيق]
في المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني بالتسبب في مقتل وجرح العشرات من
المواطنين بعد قصف مستشفى شرق النيل
بالطيران الحربي واوضحت قوات الدعم السريع
عبر حسابه على تويتر ان قصف بالطيران شمل
مستشفى شرق النيل الى جانب قصف عدد من
المصانع في المنطقه الصناعيه بحري هو عدد
من المنشات المدنيه والطبيبيه والعسكريه
[تصفيق]
في المقابل اقترح رئيس الوزراء السودانيه
السابق عبد الله حمدوك اجراء حوار عاجل
بين الجيش والدعم السريع لتوفير اساس لوقف
اطلاق النار بشكل دائم بالاضافه الى وقف
فوري لاطلاق النار يخضع للمراقبه والاتفاق
على انشاء ممرات انسانيه دائمه واقترح
حمدك ايضا اشتراك المدني السودانيين في
مفاوضات شامله واستئناف العمليه السياسيه
مؤكدا على ان استمرار الحرب في السودان
وانتشارها في رقعه اوسع قد يطر العالم
باسره لذلك نطالب
اهلا بك سالم وهل بدل مشهد في الخرطوم
اليوم مختلفا عما كان عليه في الايام
الماضيه
اهلا بك يا احمد وبكل الساده المشاهدين ما
زال الوضع كما هو عليه منذ ساعتين تقريبا
هناك هدوء نسبي حركه شبه طبيعيه في مناطق
متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم فقط شكاوى من
المواطنين تتكرر من تذبذب التيار
الكهربائي هذه هي ابرز شكوى متكرره لدى
المواطنين ويضاف اليها كذلك موضوع الامداد
المائي في المناطق المتفرقه من العاصمه
الخرطوم على ابرزها مدينه بحري وبعد ذلك
على درجات اقل من درمان والخرطوم ايضا
شكاوى المواطنين بعض السلع كذلك فيها ندره
او هناك مجهود يبذل من المواطن من اجل
الوصول الى سلع بعينها خاصه مع الحركه
التي تكون الى حد ما صعبه بالنسبه
للمواطنين في ظل عدم توفر المواصلات
بشكلها الطبيعي
مواصلات اصبحت ايضا هي هي الاخرى ايضا
ليست متوفره بالكامل خاصه في المناطق التي
تعدي مناطق الخطوره عدا ذلك هنالك ربما
هدوء حذر
في مختلف ارجاء العاصمه حتى المناطق التي
كانت دائما ما نسمع فيها الاصوات العاليه
للرصاص وكذلك اصوات المدافع والقنابل
والمدافع الثقيله والخفيفه هي باتت الان
يعني يعمها هدوء نسبي منذ ساعتين يعني هذه
الاشتباكات كانت تحدث في بدايه هذه الازمه
تتركز اكثر حول القياده العامه القصه
الجمهوري والمطار الان
سماع انفجارات في تلك المناطق النادره
نسبيا الى ما يعد ذلك سالم
نعم هو كانت قد نفذت بالامثال القوات
المسلحه السودانيه هجمات متكرره على هذه
المناطق التي هي مطار الخرطوم ومحيط مطار
الخرطوم وكذلك محيط القياده العامه للجيش
وحتى المنطقه في بحري التي تتمركز بها
قوات للدعم السريع وهي جسر شمبات الرابط
بينهم درمان وبحري من ناحيته الشرقيه اي
في مدينه بحري هنالك معسكر المظلات كما هو
معلوم في هذه المنطقه
يعني كثفت القوات الجويه السودانيه
قصفها لهذه المناطق لانها مناطق تتمركز
بها قوات للدعم السريعي يضاف اليها حتى
منطقه صالحه اقصى جنوب الخرطوم كل هذه
المناطق تتمركز بها قوات للدعم السريع كان
الجيش السوداني قد استهدف هذه المناطق
بكثافه يوم امس او اخر يوم امس في اخر
نهار يوم امس
وحتى اول الليل كذلك استمعنا الى هذا
القصف ربما هذه المناطق يعني شنت عليها
هذه الحمله في يوم امس ثم بعد ذلك توالت
مجموعه من التصريحات كان من ابرزها تصريح
عضو مجلس السياده واحد قاده الجيش
السوداني واحد من جنرالات الجيش السوداني
الفريق ياسر العطل الذي اكد انهم سيحسمون
هذا الامر في غضون اسبوعين ما بين اسبوع
الى اسبوعين وهو ربما يشير الى انه ايضا
تحدث عن ضعف كذلك ضعف
للقوات الدعم السريع وانها اصبحت في اضعف
حالاتها وان هذا الضعف بدا من الان لعله
يشير الى الهجمه التي تمت بالامس واكد
كذلك على انه لا تفاوض مع المتمردين
الهجمه
يوم على قوات الدعم السلعوه في مناطق
مختلفه في خرطوم وفي ام درمان هل ما زالت
هذه التمركزات او الارتكازات للدعم السريع
موجوده اتحدث عن الخرطوم وبحري وايضا عن
ارتكازاتهم المتواجده قرب الاذاعه
والتلفزيون
لم تتغير كثيرا الخارطه بالنسبه للخرطوم
بالتحديد وكذلك مدينه بحري الى حد ما لكن
ليس لدينا انباء دقيقه عن هذا التمركز
احمد هنا يجب ايضا ان نوضح نقطه مهمه احمد
بان تحرك هذه القوات يجعل من الحديث عن
تمركزها في منطقه دون الاخرى ايضا امر
يعني نسبي جدا ان هذه القوات تتمركز في
منطقه ثم تنسحب منها بعد ساعتين من الان
حينما ياتي الليل تجد هذه القوات عادت الى
هذه المنطقه حينما ياتي الصباح تجدها
غادرت كذلك هذه المنطقه فيصعب جدا الحديث
على تمركز دائم لهذه القوات قوات الدعم
السريع في المناطق التي نتحدث عنها دائما
فهي واحده من الامور التي تقوم بها قوات
الدعم السريعه الحركه الدائمه في المناطق
التي هي تتواجد في داخلها شكرا لك من
الخرطوم كنت معنا مراسله عربيه سالم
الهاشمي تحيه سالم
مشاهدينا مع استمرار الصراع في السودان
منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل اعلى المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه محمد ابراهيم عبد الرحمن
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه ان 39 مستشفى
خرج عن الخدمه منذ بدء الاشتباكات فيما
تحول اثناء عشر بل 12 مستشفى الى ثكنات
لقوات الدعم السريع كما قال
المستشفيات التي توقفت على الخدمه منذ
صباح يوم 15 وحتى اليوم هي 39 مستشفى هذه
المستشفيات هي في مناطق الاشتباكات حتى
تاريخ اليوم مناطق غير امنه هي المستشفيات
التي متاخمه لمناطق الاشتراك شارع القصر
وشارع
المطار
والقياده والازاحه ومركز ومركز البحري
هذا هو اكد المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال
الاحمر السوداني اسامه ابو بكر العربي ان
الهدوء في السودان نسبي وليس كاملا حيث
تشهد بعض المناطق اشتباكات مستمره
نسبيه في هدوء نسبي لكن ليس هدوء كامل
احنا عايزين هدوء كامل وعايزين هدنه
معلومه مسارات امنه واضحه كل الناس يعلمون
ففي كل الدول المحاذي الى السودان فيها
كبيره
ودخل طبعا كبير جدا والخطر برضو الكبير
جدا انه في نزوح داخلي يعني عشرات الالاف
من النازحين يخرجون من العاصمه الى شمال
السودان في كل الولايات لحتى يصلوا
المعابر وفي مناطق اليمام مستقيره اصلا
لذلك نحن لا انه لازم تكون في خطه واضحه
متفق عليها بين الطرفين
انه يعني
امنه جدا ما يكون فيها اي انتهاكات لانه
نحن عندنا فرص بتاعت دعم كبير من المؤسسات
عالميه
الان هذا سماع صوت صاروخ على ماي
[موسيقى]
اصوات للمدفعيه
ثقيله ثقيله حتى البعيد واشتباكاته واضحه
هنا ما بين الدعم السريع
والقوات الشعب المسلحه
اسمع الان بوضوح
بدوره قال سكرتيرو لنقابه الاطباء
السوداني عطيه عبد الله ان الوضع الصحيه
كارثي واصفا ما يحدث في القطاع الطبي
بالجريمه الانسانيه واضاف ان كل
المستشفيات العامه في الخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل حيث دعا اطراف الصراع لوقف القتال
فورا واكد ان الوضع الصحي كارثي في
الجنينه بدارفور محذرا من الوضع نفسه في
باقي الولايات اذا ما استمرت المواجهات
وقال عطيه ان مستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه
بسبب عدم توفر الوقود
الاوضاع في الجنينه كارثيه للغايه نعم
النظام الصحي لا زال يتهاوى لسقوط في كل
لحظه وحين بالامس عدد من خرجت خارج الخدمه
لانه لم نستطيع ايصال كوادر طبيه اليها
وبعض الاخر خرج من الخدمه لانقطاع الوقود
الجازلين وايضا هنالك يعني عدد من
الولايات تعاني من نقص في الاكسجين حتى في
ولايه الخرطوم
العوامل مجتمعه وهو ما ظللنا ان نحذر منه
منذ اليوم الاول ستؤدي الى الى نتيجه لا
نتمناها ابدا وهي انهيار النظام الصحيه
نحن نتخوف ان يحدث مع يعني يحصل ما حدث في
الجنينه في عدد من المدن وهو ما تخوف عنه
لذلك نحن مطالبه لطرفي الصراع الان هي
ايقاف هذه الحرب داخل ولايه الخرطوم هنالك
مستشفيات توقفت تماما لانه ما فيها معينات
طبيه
من القهر مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني عادل ابراهيم
حمد اهلا بالسيد عادل معنا في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه الامم المتحده كما تابعنا دقه
جرس الانذار من تحول الازمه في السودان
الى الى ماساه انسانيه هل مصطلح الماساه
هنا او الكارثه هو الوصف الادق الذي يمكن
ان يصف المشهد السوداني حاليا ام انه يحمل
قدرا من المبالغه
مرحب بك وبكل مشاهدي قناه العربيه انا
عادل سيدي احمد
حقيقه علوم ان الحرب في اي ما في مشكله
اعتز بان اكون عادل حمد
الحرب اي حرب في الدنيا لها انعكاسات
سالبه على حياه الناس
ولها اصداء فظيعه تؤثر على البعد الانساني
والبعد الصحي والبعد الامني وهذا هذا ما
يشكل الان صوره من صور الوضع في السودان
انا اعتقد انه
الاستمرار الحرب بالضروره سيخلف الكثير
جدا من المشاكل على الرغم من انه بدات في
72 ساعه الاخيره الامور نسبيا
تختلف وتتغير حيث ان الناس بدو يتحركوا في
في مناطق محدده خفت فيها اصوات المدافع
والرصاص لذلك انا اعتقد انه المساله هي
يعني مرشحه ان تتفاهم ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه
توجد مشاكل انسانيه بشكل او باخر نرجو ان
لا تصل الامور الى تدهور اكثر من ذلك
اشتباكات يوم امس في الخرطوم وصفها البعض
بانها الاعنه ربما منذ بدايه هذه الازمه
او ربما منذ بدايه هذه الهدن لكن عوده
الاشتباكات بهذا الشكل في المناطق
المختلفه من الخرطوم يوم امس هل يرتبطوا
بشكل او باخر بعمليه اجلاء الرعايه التي
راعي الاجانب طبعا التي وصلت الى مراحل
متقدمه حاليا
نعم اصلا الهدنه او الهدن التي قامت في
طبعها في طبيعها العام هي هدى يعني هشا
ليست بالقويه ولو انك لا تستطيع ان تقول
بجمله واحده انها بذات الدرجه هي تختلف من
هودني الى هدنه ولعل
عمليات الاجلاء التي تمت استفادت كثيرا من
هذه الهدم بشكل او باخر
الامر الاخر كان من الواضح ان الدعم
السريع يستقل الهدم بشكل باخر لتعزيز
مواقفه وهذا ما يعلى القوات المسلحه تتحسب
لهذا الجانب بان تحدث او تحدث بعض
التحركات اثناء هذه الهدن طيب هناك ايضا
تصنيع اخر للامير عام المتحده قبل ايام
حذر فيه من ان القبائل في السودان تسعى
للتس
لح في بعض المناطق اعتقد انه يعني قبائل
بعض قبائل دارفور هل ستاخذ هذه الازمه في
تقديرك بعد جهوي وقبليا اذا ما استمرت
بشكل الحالي
اصلا المواجهات القبليه في السودان قديمه
جدا ولعلها بدات منذ عهد الانجليز في
السودان منذ العهد الاستعماري لذلك ليس
هناك من جديد فيما يتعلق بالمواجهات
القبليه والتسليح القبليه هذه المساله
اصلا موجوده في الواقع
وظلت هاجسا في ظل الحكومات الوطنيه بعد
الاستقلال عام
1956 ولكن حتى الان انا اعتقد انه طابع
المعركه هو طابع بين جيش وبين قوه مسلحه
وما يحمد
للواقع حتى الان ان اي ابعاد اخرى اجزاء
طابع قبلي اوجها او طائفي لم تظهر في
المعركه حتى الان ولو ان هناك تخوف من ان
تتجه الامور الى هذا الجانب ما لم تتحرك
الاطراف لايجاد حلول ناجعه وموضوعيه لهذه
المواجهات يعني
تسلح هؤلاء
تسلح القبائل في السودان ربما لم يكون لم
يكن كما تفضلت شيئا جديدا لكنه في ظروف
استثنائيه هذه يعني نتحدث عن الدعم السريع
وما يتمتع به ايضا ربما من شعبيه حاضنه
شعبيه نسبيا في
بعض القبائل التي ينتمي اليها وامتدادات
هناك الا تعتقد ان ذلك ربما يدفع الدعم
السريع للتخندق هناك خاصه اذا ما ارغي مع
الخروج من العاصمه الخرطوم والمدير الكبرى
وبالتالي سيشكل هاجسا امنيا للجيش
السوداني واي حكومات مقبله
انا اتحدث
بمهنيه وبموضوعيه وبتوازن اعتقد ان الدعم
السريع في مرحله من مراحل تكوينه
كان هو نفسه في دارفور طرفا في الصراع لم
يكن هو القوه الوحيده وانما كان طرفا
اقتضته ظروف الصراع القبلي حتى ان النظام
السابق النظام المخلوع عمر البشير حينما
اسس هذه القوه اسسها على هذا الاساس كي
تخلق شكل من اشكال التوازن في في منطقه
دارفور لذلك ليس هناك اجماع على قوه الدعم
السريع في دارفور باعتبار ان هناك ممرات
تاريخيه وقعت بين هذه القوات وبين القبائل
في دارفور لذلك الحديث حول ان للدعم
السريع الشعبيه في دارفور لا يعبر عن عن
نقطه دقيقه او بعد حقيقي على الواقع والا
فان دارفور الان نسبيا لا لا تشهد عمليات
حربيه بالشكل الذي يحدث في الخرطوم
نعم طيب عادي سيدي احمد سعود اليك من جديد
مشاهدينا الحرب مستمره لكن الجهود لوقفها
متواصله ايضا دعوات عربيه وغربيه تشدد على
ضروره وقف القتال بين الجيش ودعم السريع
وفتح الباب امام الحوار
والله هذا
كلهم بامان الناس كتيره هناك عندها مشاكل
ما قادره ما عندها فلوس
كثير معلقه نحمد الله سبحانه
للمملكه هل هذا الاستحمام
[موسيقى]
في هذا السياق ابلغ وزير الخارجيه سامح
شكري مبعوثه رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
ابلغه موقف مصر الداعم لضروره بدء الحوار
شكر جدد التاكيد على ان القاهره تتعامل مع
الازمه كشان السوداني الداخلي وكانت
العاصمه المصريه القاهره قد شهدت لقاء جمع
وزير خارجيه سامح شكري بسفير دفع الحاج
علي المبعوث الخاص لرئيس المجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
في السياق قال محمد مصطفى عرفي مندوب ومصر
الدائم لدى الجامعه العربيه على الضروره
وقف اطلاق النار فورا في السودان
اننا نؤكد من هنا باسم رئاسه المجلس على
ضروره الوقف الفوري غير المشروط للعنف
واتاحه الفرصه كامله لانجاح جهود التسويه
وجعلها تؤتي ثمارها في القريب العاجل
ونحذر من هنا باسم رئاسه المجلس من ان
المساس بالمدنيين بالسودان واستهداف
منشاتهم لا سيما الطبيه منها هو امر خطير
للغايه ويمثل انتهاكا واضحا وسافرا
للقانون الدولي والقانون الدولي وفي كلمته
امام المندوبين الدائمين في الجامعه
العربيه الذين عقدوا اجتماعا في القاهره
لبحث الاوضاع في السودان جدد فهم الخمع
لنائب والمندوب الدائم للسعوديه لدى
الجامعه العربيه دعوه بلاده لايقاف
مواجهات في السودان الحفاظ على حياه
المدنيين
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تجدد دعوتها لسرعه وقف العمليات العسكريه
والتحلي باقصى درجات ضبط النفس وتجنب
التصعيد وتغليف مصلحه الشعب السوداني
للحفاظ على مكتسباته ومقدراته والعوده الى
الاتفاق الاطاري الذي يهدف الى الوصول الى
اعلان سياسي يحقق الامن والاستقرار
للسودان وشعبه الشقيق
وتؤكد المملكه على اهميه الالتزام بالهدنه
القائمه وحمايه المدنيين والبعثات
الدبلوماسيه وتوفير الممرات الامنه
للعاملين في المجال الانساني كما تؤكد
المملكه على ضروره العمل على تيسير وتامين
عمليات الاجلاء للمدنيين
من جانبه اكد امجد العضائي لا مندوب
الاردن لدى الجامعه العربيه ان كافه
الاطراف في السودان عليها التحلي
بالمسؤوليه مشددا على ضروره ايجاد حل
داخلي سوداني يعكس تطلعات السودانيين
بعيدا عن اي التدخلات خارجيه
ونؤكد ضروره تحلي كافه الاطراف بروح
المسؤوليه الوطنيه واعلاء المصالح العليا
للسوداني وشعبه الشقيق فوق اي اعتبار اخر
حقنا لدماء السودانيين وتفاديا لقتال بين
ابناء الشعب الواحد لن يكون المنتصر فيها
الا خاسرا فالقاتل والمقتول اخوه والثمن
المدفوع امن واستقرار ومنعت السوداني
واستقلاله ووحدته ووحدته ودماء ابنائه
ونؤكد ان اي حل للازمه الراهنه لابد ان
يكون حلا داخليا سودانيا يعكس اراده
وتطلعات الشعب السوداني الشقيق بعيدا عن
اي تدخلات خارجيه
يخلوها
ويرجعوا لصوت العقل والسودان كبير بيشيل
الناس كلها
المفروض الشرطه نحن المواطنين
ما بتقدر احتمال بعد شوي يجونا داخلين في
البيوت بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والله
الواحد كان مواطن سوداني يعني بيتالم
قلم شديد جدا جدا الوضع الحاطي في البلد
وانا يعني ما اقدر اقول يعني اقوم اقول
انه البلد فيها
الخدمات في البنزين وفي الوقود وكده
رئيس المسيح عبد الفتاح السيسي وفي مقابله
مع صحيفه يابانيه قال ان تدفق العديد من
السودانيين الى مصر سيخلق صعوبات في
البلاد الرئيس السيسي اشار الى ان بلاده
تتاثر بشكل واضح بنزاع في السودان في حاله
تدفق المزيد من اللاجئين خاصه ان مصر
تعاني من صعوبات اقتصاديه في ظل الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا كما اضاف ان مصر في
الاصل استقبلت اكثر من ثمانيه ملايين لاجئ
من السودان وليبيا وسوريا واليمن ودول
اخرى كما عبر عن رغبته في التعاون مع
اليابان لوقف اطلاق النار في السودان ومنع
امتداد تاثير الازمه للمنطقه
مشاهدينا نعود الى القاهره وضيفنا السيد
عادل السيد احمد الكاتب والمحل السياسي من
جديد هناك ما يوصف بغياب واضح للجامعه
العربيه من ما يحدث الان في السودان
التحدث عن اليوم الثامن عشر من هذه
المعارك والمواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع ولا اجتماع
للجامعه العربيه تحديدا على مستوى الوزراء
الخارجيه على الاقل تقدير لم يعد ذلك في
تقديرك
يعني هذا الجانب واضح وباين يعني في
الساحه الان ان الجامعه العربيه تقوم
باجتهادات على مستوى ممثل الدول ولكن من
المطلوب ومن المرجو مواكبه التطورات
المؤسفه والخطيره في السودان بعقد جلسه
طارئه تبدا ربما بوزراء الخارجيه ثم ان
دعى الامر ان ترتفع الى مستوى الرؤساء
حقيقه الجامعه العربيه بدات في 72 ساعه
الماضيه تتحرك بجديه
واتوقع ان يرتفع مستوى التمثيل داخل
الجامعه العربيه من المناديب الى
الى الوزراء الخارجيه هل ترى ان الحل حل
هذه الازمه هو حل سوداني سوداني ام انه حل
ذو ابعد خارجيه
يجب ان ننظر لهذا الامر ببعدين هناك بعده
عسكري على الارض يقوم على
مواجهه هي التعبير الدقيق هو هي عمليه
عمليه عسكريه وليست حرب التعبير الدقيق ان
هناك عمليه عسكريه بين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وبين فصيل او وحده عسكريه تسمى
بقوات الدعم السريع
ربما تحسم المعركه على الارض
لانه لا يوجد توازن هو اصلا بين الطرفين
هذا على مستوى الحرب وعلى مستوى الميداني
ولكن يؤمل كذلك ان يتم حصم الحرب على
المستوى السياسي والدبلوماسي وانا اعتقد
انه هناك مبادرات سودانيه وطنيه تقوم بها
شخصيات وتقوم بها قوه مجتمع مدني وسياسي
بجانب المبادرات الاقليميه والدوليه كلها
في النهايه تسعى الى وقف الحرب وتسعى الى
ايات تسويه
[موسيقى]
حتى الان لم تبرز بشكل واضح صراعه المصالح
ولكن ربما يتطور الامر فيما بعد ان تواصل
امد الحرب ان تدخل حسابات المصالح في في
هذه الحرب حتى الان اعتقد انه المبادرات
المطروحه ولعل اخرها المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه كلها تهدف الى وقف الحرب والى
سياده روح السلام والطمانينه داخل السودان
انا اعتقد انه المساله لا زالت تحت دائره
السيطره ما لم تحدث تطورات اخرى في الايام
القادمه تفتح مجالات لاشياء اخرى لا سمح
الله هل هناك طرف في الداخل السوداني يمكن
القول انه مستفيد مما يحدث الان في البلاد
بكل شك نحن في السودان لنا مقوله شعبيه
عريره جدا اسمها اسمها المديده حركتني اذا
تصارع طرفان يظهر طرف ثالث ثالث يحاول
بقدر الامكان تاجيج هذا الصراع ولعل فنون
النظام السابق بعد ان خرجوا من المشهد
نهائيا بثوره ديسمبر
ظلوا منذ سقوطهم يبحثون عن وسائل شتى لخلق
عدم استقرار هم المستفيدون الحقيقيون الان
من استمرار الصراع وتاجيجه يجب على
الاطراف ان تنتبه الى هذا الجانب سواء
كانت القوات المسلحه والقوات السياسيه او
خلافه ان لا تعطي لفنون النظام السابق اي
سانحه كي يستفيدوا من الوضع المازوم الان
في السودان طيب كيف سيخدم الوضع الحالي
مصالح فلان نظام السابق سيد عادل
ف النظام السابق هم مثل هولاكو
يرددون مقوله علي وعلى اعدائي بالطبع فانه
لانهم لم يجدوا موطي غنم بعد الثوره
السودانيه العظيمه فلذلك يسعون بشتى السبل
لخلق عدم استقرار ولخلق مواجهات ولخلق
مشاحنات بين الاطراف انا اعتقد انه هذه
المساله واضحه حتى ان غاده الجيش انفسهم
ظلوا يرددون انهم لن يتوانوا في الدفاع عن
المدنيه في السودان وعن التحول الديمقراطي
انا اعتقد ان اليتم الذي وقع على جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين في السودان جعلهم يبحثون
بشتى السبل عن اي طريقه
لاشعال نيران في السودان الخطاب الذي
يتبناه قاده الدعم السريع في الفتره
الاخيره ومنذ اشتعل هذه الازمه ايضا هو ان
القرار داخل القوات المسلحه هو بيد الفل
نظام السابق يعني ما رايك في هذا الطرح
اعتقد جازم وانا اتحدث من موقع المهنيه
ومن موقع الاستقلاليه ان هذا الكلام
للاستهلاك السياسي لان السودانيين
النسوا لن ينسوا ان قوات الدعم السريع اذا
اصلا الناس ذهبت في مثل هذه الاتجاهات فان
الدعم سريع اصلا تم تاسيسه في ظل النظام
السابقه عام 2013
بمرسوم من الرئيس المخلوع ثم بصم على هذا
القرار المجلس الوطني والذي كان قوامه
الحزب الحاكم حزب المؤتمر الوطني
باطفاء شرعيه لهذه القوات اذا القوات
الدعم السريع هي صنيعه اخوانيه في الاساس
ولكن انا ارجو ان لا يذهب الناس في هذه
الاتجاهات وان لا يكون هناك استهلاك سياسي
من شانه استدرار العواطف السودانيون الان
اصبحوا في غمه من الوعي وفي قمه من
الادراك بحيث انهم لا يمكن ان يخضع وا من
هؤلاء الذين كانوا يتحدثون باسم الدين او
من اولئك الذين يدعون الان ادعاءات ليست
حقيقيه من القاهره كنت معنا الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني عادل سيدي احمد
شكرا لك استاذ عادل
ووسط مخاوف من تفاقم الاوضاع في غرب
السودان اعلن حاكم اقليم دار فرميني اركم
النووي عن التوصل لاتفاق شعبي في ولايه
غرب دارفور لوقف القتال القبلي وادعم
الناوي عبر حسابه على تويتر القبائل في
غرب دارفور لعدم الانصياع لاي تعصب قبري
ونجدهم بالحفاظ على النسيج الاجتماعي
وشهدت مدينه الجنينه بولايه غرب دارف
والاشتباكات بين قبيله المساليف والقبائل
العربيه اثر الصراع بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في المدينه اوقعت اكثر من 90 قتيلا
في حديث خاص مع العربيه قال المبعوث
الاممي الى السودان سيدنا العمل جاري لوضع
التفاصيل لمفاوضات السودان مع الامريكيين
والسعوديين ورجح ان تجري مفاوضات الحل بل
ان تجرى مفاوضه الحل في السعوديه
اداره
الاعمال
الفنيه واللوجستيكيه هلا مع الامريكان
والسعوديين فبطئت بالارجا
سيتم بالمحاز الارجح طبعا يعني الجانبين
لازم ان يوافقا على
هذا المكان
وانا ما بحكي هلا انت افوت سياسي انا بحكي
عن محادثات او الحلول فنيه الى هذه الماء
لانشاء وتاسيس اليه
لوقفه لك نار دائم وثابت مع اليه مراقبه
والتحكم على وقفه لكنر على صعيد الانسانيه
الدوليه قرر الامين العام المتحده
في حاله الطوارئ ووكيل الامين العام
للشؤون الانسانيه الى السودان لاستكشاف
سبل تقديم الاغاثه الفوريه لملايين
الاشخاص الذين انقلبت حياتهم راسا على عقب
بسبب قتال الدائر في السودان وحتى الان
احصت الامم المتحده نزوح اكثر من 330 الف
سوداني داخل البلاد فيما عبر نحو 100 الف
الحدود نحو الدول المجاوره
بجانبه اكد المتحدث باسم الامين العام
المتحده ستيفان
ان المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين تخطط لاستقبال اكثر من 800 الف
شخص قد يفرون من القتال في السودان الى
الدول المجاوره
يدعم صندوق الامم المتحده للسكان الشركاء
على الارض بالرعايه الصحيه المنقذه للحياه
ومعدات الولاده الامنه تخطط المفوضيه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
بالتشاور مع الحكومات والشركاء لاستقبال
اكثر من 800 الف شخص قد يفرون من القتال
في السودان الى الدول السبع المجاوره تؤكد
احدث الارقام من فرقنا على الارض ان 73
الف شخص قد وصلوا الى البلدان المجاوره
مما في ذلك اللاجئون السودانيون ولا سيما
من جنوب السودان
استشهاد المجاوره نازح ما يقرب من 20000
لاجئ سوداني اغلبيتهم يا النساء والاطفال
الذين يعاني بعضهم من امراض تنفسيه خطيره
غير ان اليونسيف حذرت من البقاء في قريه
كوفرون ارشاديه خوفا من موسم الامطار
المقبل
خطا نهايتها عصيه طريق اللجوء يطول وصلنا
وحيدات الى تشاد لاجئه سودانيه دون مواعيد
بعضهن تمكنا من الدفع فقل عليهن عبء
الطريق نساء واطفال هربوا من حرب اشتعلت
فجاه خيار اللجوء لا مفر منه ضمن حرب
بحصيله كبيره للقتله
البيوت وقد قتلوا ثلاثه نفر اربعه كده
عشان كذا
استقروا هنا على الحدود الارشاديه
السودانيه كبرات السن لم تعد لهن القدره
على المضي بينما الاطفال اغلبهم يعانون من
امراض تنفسيه وسوء تغذيه
20,000 لاجئ سوداني استقروا في قريه كفرون
تشاديه قريه تفتقر لاساسيات الحياه وضروره
تغيير المكان باتت حتميه
اذا فشلنا في التحرك الان سيفوت الاوامر
سياتي موسم الامطار قريبا واذا لم نقدم
مساعده للناس سيتم اغلاق الطريق وسيظل
اللاجئون عالقين هنا
يبدو ان البقاء هنا طويل مخيم اللجوء باتت
تتشكل ملامحه عشرات الاسقف واعمده علها
تشد بيت لاجئ الى حين عوده غيداء السالم
العربيه
فيما في الاجلات واصل السعوديه جهودها
لاستقبال الهاربين من جحيم الحرب في
السودان وحتى الان تم اجلاء اكثر من خمسه
الاف رعيه اجنبي من مئه دوله صباح اليوم
الثلاثاء غادرت طائره صينيه مطار الملك
عبد العزيز الدولي بجده وعلى متنها 185
مواطنا تم اجلائهم من السودان وفي مشهد
مؤثر لعمليه اجلاء نقل افراد من البحريه
السعوديه شابا من ذوي الاعاقه من ميناء
بورسودان الى سطح سفينه الدرعيه المتجهه
الى جده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العربيه الثاني
عبر ثلاث قوافل في وقت كان البيت الابيض
قد اعلن نشر طائرات لمراقبه عمليه الاجلاء
ليس هناك اي عدد محدد نصح عنه لاعداد
المواطنين الامريكيين الذين غادروا
السودان المواطنون الامريكيون هم من
يتخذون القرار بشان المغادره بحسب
اولوياتهم تواصلنا خلال هذه الازمه مع
اكثر من 5000 مواطن امريكي مقيم في
السودان واجلينا مواطن منهم عبر ثلاث
قوافل
الخارجيه الامريكيه جهود السعوديه في
استقبال المواطنين الامريكيين وايضا
للمساعده في عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
عموما
اود القول ان السعوديه لعبت دورا مهما ليس
فقط في استقبال مواطنين لكن في دعم
الرباعيه وكانت حلقه وصل في الدفع بتمديد
هدنه الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه في مصر تستمر
عمليات استقبال السودانيين الفارين من
الاشتباكات في بلادهم اغلب القادمين ياتون
من خلال منفذ قسطل البري ومن بعده يصلون
لمدينه ابو سمبل عن طريق عبارات نهر النيل
احمد عثمان وتفاصيل في التقرير التالي
نحن الان امام المرسى النيلي لمدينه ابو
سمبل في انتظار العبارات النيليه القادمه
والتي يستقلها السودانيون القادمون عبر
منفذ قسطل البري في اصعب من كيد كونك تخلي
دارك
بدايه الحرب في المنازل انعطاع التيار
الكهربائي الميه ما فيش ما فيش ولا حاجه
وعلى الرغم من استمرار تدفق القادمين من
السودان الى مصر باعداد كبيره الا ان هناك
من يفضل استقلال نفس الحافلات للعوده الى
السودان حاليا السودان في ازمه
واهالي الخرطوم كلهم جايين الى مصر هذا
المكان يعد مكانا للراحه للقادمين
المرهقين من السودان قبل ان يستانفوا
رحلاتهم مره اخرى سواء الى اسوان او الى
القاهره وجدنا تعاون طيب جدا حقيقه من
اخواننا المصريين
ومع غروب الشمس تتوقف حركه العبارات
النيليه لينتظر الجميع سطوع شمس يوم جديد
لكل من يريد ان يذهب او ياتي الى الاراضي
المصريه من السودان احمد عثمان لقناتي
العربيه والحدث من مدينه ابو سمبل محافظه
اسوان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات